la software république c'est l'histoire
d'une collaboration entre cinq grands
industriels français le groupe renault
atos dassault systèmes
stmicroelectronics et thales et pour
parler de ce sujet nous sommes avec
françois dosse à bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le responsable de la sauve toi
république pour le groupe renault
quel est l'objectif de ce programme
industriel
alors vous le savez puisqu'on en a déjà
pas mal parler l'idée c'est de créer un
écosystème qui va travailler sur les
logiciels
pourquoi travailler sur les logiciels
parce que les logiciels finalement c'est
la valeur future du véhicule de demain
et de la mobilité de demain
donc il va y avoir énormément d'avancées
dans ses logiciels
alors on aurait pu le faire tout seul on
a préféré s'associer à des champions
comme tous ceux que vous avez cités plus
nous pour le faire ensemble parce qu'on
pense qu'on sera beaucoup plus efficace
et beaucoup plus fort si on le fait
ensemble
le qg n'a sauf toi république sera dans
le bâtiment odyssée le nouveau bâtiment
du technocentre renault de guyancourt
ce sera sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines déjà pourquoi ce
choix
exactement alors on sera on sera ici
parce que on est vous savez au début du
plateau de saclay et le plateau de
saclay c'est un plateau d'intelligence
d' expertise de grands entreprises de
centres de recherche des meilleures
universités françaises et donc on aura
cette proximité
on a aussi sur le plateau de saclay
beaucoup de startups qui sont déjà
actives dans les domaines qui nous
intéresse l'intelligence artificielle la
cybersécurité et donc on pense qu'on va
pouvoir catalyser autour de nous autour
de ce bâtiment que vous avez mentionné
qui est un bâtiment tout neuf
magnifique tout en bois et verre très
collaboratif et voilà donc on sera c'est
pour ça qu'on a voulu cet endroit sur le
plateau de saclay nous c'est que c'est
comme ça qu'on le conte exprime cinq
industriels fondateur vous parlez des
start-up ya aussi des centres de
recherche qui peut être concerné
pourquoi parce que nous sommes dans une
démarche d'open innovation c'est comme
ça que vous l'imaginez l'open innovation
pour développer la mobilité de demain
absolument en fait l'on parle
d'écosystèmes c'est un écosystème est un
écosystème ouvert
large donc effectivement vous avez bien
vu il ya les cinq groupes que vous avez
nommés mais on sera pas que les salles
qui en aura d'autres qui vont venir des
grandes entreprises des entreprises
moyennes des petites entreprises
bien sûr des start up ça c'est très
important les centres de recherche de
façon à ce qu'on est toute la chaîne
bhoutan goût des logiciels vous avez que
c'est un monde qui est très évolutif où
les choses ont très très vite et donc
pour nous notamment avoir ces startups
qu'une capacité de créer en permanence
des choses très disruptive très
novatrice pour nous c'est très important
vous avez cité un chacun le domaine
d'activité il ya l'intelligence
artificielle ia la big data il ya les
composants électroniques
il ya la mobilité l'automobile avec le
groupe renault et puis il ya la
cybersécurité comme en agglomère toutes
ces activités pour proposer justement d
offre des solutions pour la mobilité de
demain
alors on le fait d'être très bonne
question parce qu'effectivement il faut
que chacun apporte sa contribution à
d'abord un premier temps on s'est bien
rendu compte qu'il n'y avait pas de
dover la banque hre les uns et les
autres chacun effectivement apporte sa
brique et comment on le fait en fait on
le fait en portant de cas d'application
très concret et on dit voilà sur ce cas
là est ce qu'on est tous d'accord qu un
intérêt oui alors qu'est ce que chacun
peut apporter
moi je peux apporter cette brique
technologique moi j'apporte samoa et ont
bâti comme ça ensemble une offre où on
arrive à faire finalement une offre
complète qu'aucun de nous tous seuls on
arriverait à faire c'est ça qui est
finalement la force de cette de cet
écosystème et où vous l'aurez compris en
fait c'est pas qu'on additionne c'est
plutôt qu'on multiplie donc un effet
vraiment des multiplicateurs qui est
très fort
quand vous parlez du zèle ça peut être
quoi par exemple illustre alors on a
annoncé déjà un certain nombre de
projets un projet qui est le projet de
plug in charge où on pourra charger sur
des bornes n'importe quelle voiture
électrique alors qu'aujourd'hui vous
savez que chacun à son système le
système ne sont pas compatibles et c'est
donc une facilité beaucoup plus grande
pour les utilisateurs et donc ça c'est
faire que des software afin dé logiciels
se parlez-en aux autres etc
pour faciliter la vie des consommateurs
et l'autre qui alors là vous allez le
comprendre encore plus important je
dirais
et s'adresse aux collectivités les aider
à faire des simulations de flux parce
que vous savez qu'on vit encore dans
beaucoup d'embouteillages
beaucoup d'accidents beaucoup de vies
sont encore malheureusement perdu de
tous les ans est donc là la software
république va proposer aux collectivités
aux villes qu'elles soient grandes ou
petites
des solutions pour gérer leurs flux
d'une façon très différente et qui va
faciliter là aussi la vie des citoyens
des consommateurs de dernière question
comment chacun va y trouver son compte à
leur foi entre les cinq industriels mais
aussi les startups à ce qu'on sait
parfois que les entrepreneurs peuvent
être frileux a collaboré avec des grands
groupes de peur d'être absorbé de perdre
un peu l'essence même de leur société
alors les start up est très claire on ne
va pas proposer de les racheter
ce que vous avez raison si on rachète
une start-up la chance qu elle ne se
retrouve pas dans des grands groupes et
très grande donc l'idée est plutôt de
les aider en investissant dans ces
start-up mais de façon minoritaire de
façon à respecter leur identité leur
façon de travailler mais en leur donnant
quand même la chance de pouvoir
travailler avec nous et notamment
d'avoir accès à des volumes beaucoup
plus important et donc ça on pense que
c'est un peu le win win le gagnant
gagnant tant pour la start-up que pour
nous donc plutôt investissement
minoritaire et après travail en commun
pour ensemble aussi constituer cet
écosystème est la dernière question en
lien un peu avec ce que vous dites
un investissement mettre à disposition
peut-être des locaux comment ça va se
mettre en place
concrètement à partir du mois de
septembre parce que le bâtiment odyssée
sera inauguré au mois de septembre
comment ça va se mettre en place
quelle forme ça va prendre avec
peut-être des incubateurs je sais pas ce
bâtiment ce sera un espèce de l'awb très
intéressant dans lequel on sera tous les
membres fondateurs que dont on a parlé
déjà depuis le début mais également
d'autres les start up par exemple alors
je vous donne un exemple refaire des
lacaton les start up qui vont gagner
c'est là qu'a t-on on va les loger on va
leur dire voilà pendant un an vous êtes
gratuitement ici avec nous pour
travailler avec nous plus profondément
on voudrait effectivement avoir un
incubateur de start up et un
accélérateur donc prendre des start up
qui match avec ce qu'on veut faire pour
les incubés ensuite les accélérer les
passer à l'échelle et si elle gagne on
gagne
à nouveau toujours dans cette dans cette
relation gagnant gagnant
l'idée de ce qu'on veut faire c'est
vraiment créer un espèce de lab ou comme
le dit moi mon patron
en fait c'est à la machine à café que on
discute et qu'on va échanger et qu'on va
se comprendre et qu'on va créer et donc
c'est ça le bâtiment odyssée c'est un
peu toute cette idée de ce laboratoire
un peu nouveau qui travers à cet
écosystème
merci françois doz ça c'est moi qui vous
remercie responsable de la sof toilettes
publiques pour le groupe renault